[Musik]
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Heute ist es wieder soweit: Murat ist am Start.
MURAT: Ja. Keine Angst, ich werde nicht kochen. Also...
SALLY: Hä? Ich hab gedacht, wir backen jetzt zusammen?
MURAT: Nein. Ich muss auf die Baustelle.
Wir sind gerade in der Endphase...
SALLY: Ja.
MURAT: ... von der Baustelle und da läuft gerade...
SALLY: Das sagt er schon wie lange, Josh?
MURAT: Ich weiß es. Wer jemals...
SALLY: Seit...
JOSH: Seit letztes Jahr.
MURAT: Ja, das Problem ist halt
SALLY: ... 8 Monaten.
MURAT: Jemand, der gebaut hat, weiß ganz genau,
was da alles schieflaufen kann.
Und da ist gerade gehörig was schief.
SALLY: Aber komm! Wenn wir jetzt noch einmal bauen,
dann wird es richtig.
MURAT: Ich hab echt keine Lust mehr.
SALLY: Ich auch nicht.
MURAT: Ich hab echt die Schnauze voll, jetzt ohne Spaß!
SALLY: Ich auch. Egal
MURAT: Reden wir nicht drüber.
SALLY: Wir reden über Süßigkeiten.
MURAT: Ja.
SALLY: Die Community hat sich gewünscht:
MURAT: Milka Tender.
SALLY: Milka Tender.
Deswegen gibt es heute wieder ein Nachgemacht-Video.
[Stimmt zu]
Milka Tender mit Kirsche habe ich schon einmal gemacht.
MURAT: Ja.
SALLY: Schwarzwälder Art.
MURAT: Kann ich mich daran erinnern. War auch richtig genial.
SALLY: Das war richtig lecker. Und ich habe mir gedacht:
Jetzt machen wir Milka Tender normal, Standard.
MURAT: Es ist keine Produktplatzierung.
Kein Unternehmen bezahlt dich für das,
dass du ihre Produkte nachbaust, aber es ist einfach...
SALLY: ... und kopierst.
MURAT: ... und kopierst.
SALLY: ... und Rezepte veröffentlichst.
MURAT: Genau. Da muss man eigentlich immer Angst haben,
dass man eine Anzeige kriegt, wenn man das macht.
SALLY: Was war eigentlich mit der Anzeige vom HSV?
MURAT: Ja.
SALLY: Das haben auch Leute schon gefragt.
MURAT: Da ist nichts. Das ist...
SALLY: Nichts mehr gekommen, oder?
MURAT: Der HSV hat nichts mehr gemacht, nein.
SALLY: Ah ja, was soll das auch oder?
MURAT: Die haben genug zu tun in der 2. Liga.
Ja. Auf jeden Fall...
SALLY: Ich guck mal.
MURAT: Schon lange nicht mehr gegessen, muss ich ehrlich sagen.
SALLY: Ich habe es, glaube ich, noch nie gegessen.
Vielleicht... Ich weiß es nicht. Aber Kirsche habe ich schon gegessen.
Ehm, was hier drin ist: Alpenmilchschokolade, Weizenmehl, Ei, Zucker.
Klar hat man dann auch Stoffe mit dabei, die das Ganze frisch
und saftig halten - muss man auch, muss man offen dazu sagen,
denn die Biskuitrolle soll ja nicht nur eine Woche halten,
sondern etwas länger.
MURAT: Darum geht's auch oftmals. Es geht gar nicht darum,
dass die euch was Böses reinmachen wollen, ...
SALLY: Nein.
MURAT: ... sondern die machen Dinge dran, ...
SALLY: Was halt rein muss.
MURAT: ... was rein muss, damit es länger hält
oder dass es glänzt oder dass es saftig ist.
Das hat damit zu tun: Der Kunde erwartet das einfach.
[Knistern]
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr würdet einen Kuchen backen
und stellt den Kuchen jetzt mal 3 Monate in ein Regal. So.
SALLY: Hmm!
MURAT: Hmm!
SALLY: Schokoladig-vanillig.
[Murat stimmt zu]
MURAT: Ja. Schokolade und Vanille. Ich schmecke nichts Anderes als...
SALLY: Mache ich nach. Also ich muss sagen:
Mein Fall ist es nicht so, weil es mir zu süß ist.
[Murat stimmt zu]
Aber ich mag auch keine Vollmilchschokolade, sondern Zartbitter-.
MURAT: Könnte ein bisschen weniger süß sein, fällt mir auch gerade auf.
SALLY: Bisschen weniger süß, und ich bin halt Zartbitter-Fan.
Darf ich zartbitter machen?
[Murat stimmt zu]
Das kann ja jeder zu Hause entscheiden, ob zartbitter oder Vollmilch,
aber ich...
Wenn ich an Schokolade denke, denke ich an dunkle Schokolade,
an viel Kakao - und dadurch wird es auch weniger süß.
Deswegen nehme ich einfach die einzige Änderung:
Zartbitterschokolade.
Dafür stelle ich jetzt erst einmal einen Biskuit her.
Ein Biskuit ist wirklich auch aus wenigen einfachen Zutaten hergestellt.
Ich muss persönlich sagen:
Wenn ich jetzt Lust hätte auf Milka Tender,
würde ich nicht losziehen und das kaufen gehen,
sondern für mich ist es schneller, ich backe es einfach kurz selber.
MURAT: Da ist... Das Einzige, was ich nicht verstehe, ist Salz.
SALLY: Doch! Habe ich doch auch.
MURAT: Ja
SALLY: Okay. Ich zeige euch einmal die Zutaten.
Kannst du mir noch eine frische Packung geben?
Ich würde die gern so hinstellen.
Danke schön!
MURAT: Ja.
SALLY: Dann zeige ich euch einmal die Zutaten für den Biskuit.
Für den Biskuit nehme ich 4 Eier, 100g Zucker, 1 Prise Salz,
etwas Vanilleextrakt, 100g Mehl und 1 TL Backpulver.
Ihr könnt jetzt ein ganz normales Handrührgerät
oder eine Küchenmaschine nehmen.
Die Eier kommen hier rein. Die sollten möglichst zimmerwarm sein.
Früher hat man auch ganz gerne dann immer pro Ei
1 EL heißes Wasser dazugegeben, denn wenn die Eier zimmerwarm sind,
lassen sie sich viel voluminöser aufschlagen
und das dauert auch nicht so lange.
Ich nehme jetzt noch 1 Prise Salz, den Zucker
und das Vanilleextrakt dazu.
Wie gesagt: Handrührgerät oder Küchenmaschine.
Auf jeden Fall sollte die Eierzuckermasse jetzt lange verrührt werden,
schon so etwa 10 Minuten.
[Musik]
So sieht die Masse jetzt aus.
Wenn ihr sie wirklich so voluminös aufgeschlagen habt,
braucht ihr eigentlich kein Backpulver.
Das sage ich auch immer wieder.
Bei Biskuit braucht man es nicht,
wenn man die Masse sehr cremig und luftig aufschlägt.
Falls ihr aber nur ein Handrührgerät habt,
dann nehmt lieber Backpulver dazu.
Also ich könnte es jetzt eigentlich weglassen.
Jetzt habe ich es schon reingeschüttet. Ist okay!
Das Mehl und das Backpulver werden jetzt hier dazu gesiebt.
Dann vorsichtig unterheben.
So ein Biskuit ist echt einer der schnellsten Teige,
die man herstellen und backen kann.
Den Ofen habe ich auch bereits vorgeheizt auf
210°C Ober-/Unterhitze,
denn ein Biskuit wird immer heiß und kurz gebacken,
damit er nicht austrocknet.
Jetzt nehme ich hier
mein Lochblech mit Dauerbackfolie mit dem Backrahmen.
Kann die Masse einfüllen, glattstreichen
und dann etwa 9 Minuten backen. Also wirklich nur ganz, ganz kurz.
So, jetzt hier schön gleichmäßig verteilen.
[Musik]
Und backen!
So sieht der Biskuit perfekt aus.
Und jetzt am besten direkt nach dem Backen auslösen.
Habe ich gerade "auslösen" gesagt? Ich meinte herauslösen.
[Musik]
Jetzt nehmt ihr euch ein sauberes Geschirrtuch -
könnt da ein bisschen Zucker draufstreuen,
damit der Biskuit nicht anklebt.
Da stürzt ihr die Platte darauf.
Sieht immer so gefährlich aus, gell?
Aber ich weiß einfach, dass er hier an der Backfolie gut haftet,
bis ich ihn dann ablöse.
Jetzt die Backfolie wegnehmen.
Damit der Biskuit schon einmal in die richtige Form kommt,
einfach mit dem Geschirrtuch aufrollen.
Ihr seht schon: Der ist richtig schön luftig, saftig.
Was ich hier schon immer einmal erwähnen wollte:
Ich wasch meine Handtücher und Geschirrtücher immer ohne Weichspüler
und ich glaube, das ist auch ganz wichtig, gerade wenn ihr
die Geschirrtücher in der Küche für Kuchen z. B. benutzt.
Denn bei Weichspüler habt ihr das Problem,
das wird ja praktisch nach dem Waschgang, also nach dem Schleudern
nach dem Waschmittel ausgewaschen
und dann kommt Waschmittel, ehm, Weichspüler drauf
und der bleibt ja dann praktisch auf den Fasern.
Das bedeutet, wenn ihr jetzt hier ein Geschirrtuch habt,
mit Weichspüler dran?
Zum einen nimmt das Geschirrtuch nicht so viel Feuchtigkeit auf,
weil einfach die Fasern benetzt sind mit Weichspüler,
und zum anderen habt ihr dann den Weichspüler in eurem Kuchen.
Also solltet ihr euch vielleicht überlegen,
den nicht einfach wegzulassen.
Ist der neu? Nö, mit Perwoll gewachsen - mit Perwoll gebacken.
Ist mir gerade eingefallen.
[Musik]
Wo wir gerade bei praktischen Tipps sind:
Ich werde auch immer wieder gefragt,
wie man die Dauerbackfolie sauber bekommt.
Ich meine, ihr könnt sie jetzt nehmen
und im Waschbecken mit dem Schwamm reinigen,
aber ich mache es immer so: Wenn ich auch sehe, da hängt noch Teig dran,
nehmt ihr eine Teigkarte,
[Schabt]
schabt den Teig erst einmal runter.
Dann habt ihr das schon einmal nicht am Schwamm kleben.
[Musik]
Ich habe noch Löffeldessert im Kühlschrank.
Josh, das können wir dann draufgeben. Das schmeißen wir nicht weg.
Jetzt könnt ihr die Backfolie einfach mit einem Schwamm
und Spülmittel von beiden Seiten im Waschbecken reinigen,
abtropfen lassen, abspülen natürlich vorher und dann trocknen.
Wenn sie ganz trocken sind, rolle ich sie zusammen
und lagere sie wieder.
Sie dürfen auch in die Spülmaschine,
aber gerade bei so trockenem Biskuit, muss ich sagen,
lohnt sich das gar nicht und ich wasche sie dann eben per Hand.
Die Backbleche reinigt ihr übrigens - also das sieht jetzt noch gut aus
und ist schön sauber, auch nicht fettig -
aber wenn ich merke, die sind fettig oder es ist einmal was eingebrannt,
kommen die in die Spülmaschine.
Wenn richtig etwas eingebrannt ist,
nehme ich einfach einen Backofenreiniger,
grad bei diesen Edelstahlblechen klappt das auch ganz gut.
Sallys Tipps sind jetzt fertig.
Die Biskuitrolle ist jetzt abgekühlt. Jetzt kann ich die Creme herstellen.
Da habe ich mir jetzt eine Mascarpone-Creme überlegt.
Und zwar brauche ich dafür
250g Mascarpone, 60g gezuckerte Kondensmilch, etwas Vanilleextrakt,
400g Sahne und San-apart zum Steifschlagen.
Ich glaube, so bekomme ich in etwa die Konsistenz hin.
Ich muss fairerweise dazu sagen, man hat nicht so viel von der Creme
rausgeschmeckt,
weil es so eine Masse war. Aber egal, ich kriege das hin.
Die gezuckerte Kondensmilch, falls ihr die nicht habt,
könnt ihr auch einfach Puderzucker benutzen.
Ich habe die jetzt ehrlicherweise auch nur genommen, weil
auf der Rückseite der Verpackung auch gezuckerte Kondensmilch
aufgeführt ist und ich glaube, die trägt schon dazu bei,
dass diese Creme milchig schmeckt.
Deswegen auch Mascarpone.
Ich hatte übrigens auch vor ein paar Monaten schon
- hat einmal jemand geschrieben:
Heißt es der, die oder das Mascarpone? Überlegt es euch.
Ich habe immer "die" Mascarpone gesagt, und das ist falsch.
Es heißt:
[Scheinwerfer und Wer wird Millionär-Musik]
A: der, B: die oder C: das?
Die richtige Antwort ist A, der Mascarpone.
IM HINTERGRUND: Was?!
SALLY: Jetzt sagt mir bitte nicht, dass ich der einzige Mensch bin,
der dachte, es heißt "die" Mascarpone.
Das tut mir echt leid, aber
in all meinen Büchern, die ich geschrieben habe,
steht "die" Mascarpone drin. Das hat nicht einmal der Lektor bemerkt.
Egal.
Ich finde, ich reiche es ein beim Duden. Ich sage, das heißt "die".
Mir egal.
Aber wenn es "der" heißt...
Jetzt könnt ihr... verrührt sie einfach! [Handrührgerät]
Ihn! Verrührt "ihn" einfach! Oah!
Gießt jetzt langsam die Sahne dazu, bei niedriger Stufe.
Es ist wirklich schwierig für Menschen, finde ich, die Artikel
in ihrer Sprache nicht kennen,
und dann kommen daher nach Deutschland und dann die Artikel lernen,
das ist schon - das ist echt nur Auswendiglernerei,
weil da gibt es ja keine plausible Logik dahinter und keine Erklärung.
Es ist einfach nur Auswendiglernen: "der" Tisch, aber "die" Stühle.
Erkläre das mal einem.
Ja.
[Handrührgerät]
Deswegen redet mein Papa so, wie er spricht,
weil im Türkischen gibt es sie nicht.
[Handrührgerät]
Deswegen türkisch immer "dem".
Jetzt könnt ihr die Creme steifschlagen,
gerne San-apart dazu nehmen zum Steifschlagen.
[Musik]
Dann jetzt hier vorsichtig auseinanderrollen.
Ich liebe Biskuitrollen.
Dann hier die Creme rein.
Grad am unteren Rand wirklich etwas mehr,
denn das sorgt dann dafür, dass die Biskuitrolle auch schön rund wird,
was man vom Original
nicht ganz so behaupten kann. [Lacht]
Schaut mal, ich nehme dann immer gern so eine Teigkarte
hier an den Rand. Dann könnt ihr nämlich die Creme
bis zum Rand streichen, ohne dass sie euch überquillt.
[Musik]
Hier ganz unten lasse ich ein bisschen Platz.
Also nicht bis ganz zum Rand streichen.
Hier jetzt schön darauf achten, dass es schön gleichmäßig ist.
Also keine Hubbel,
denn ansonsten wird die Rolle auch nicht gleichmäßig.
Dann vorsichtig aufrollen mit Hilfe des Tuches.
[Musik]
Also ich finde, die Rolle macht ihrem Namen alle Ehre.
Die ist nämlich sehr Tender, sehr leicht.
So. Und so kommt sie erst einmal in den Kühlschrank.
[Musik]
Die Biskuitrolle ist jetzt perfekt durchgekühlt.
Jetzt kommt noch natürlich die Schokoladenhülle.
Wie gesagt: Ihr könnt Vollmilch- oder Zartbitterkuvertüre nehmen.
Ich habe jetzt hier Zartbitterkuvertüre.
Und zwar wisst ihr schon, dass ich seit einiger Zeit
Schokoladen- bzw. Kuvertüre-Chips benutze.
Es ist wirklich so, dass die Qualität der Schokolade
sehr ausschlaggebend darüber ist, ob sie gut wird oder nicht.
Ich habe euch ja schon oft diese Impfmethode gezeigt,
das heißt, wie temperiert man Schokolade richtig,
dass man eben keinen Grauschleier bekommt,
dass die Kuvertüre auch bei Raumtemperatur fest ist usw. usf.
Das bedeutet einfach, die Kuvertüre aufteilen in 2/3, 1/3.
Dann erwärmt man 2/3 davon über einem warmen Wasserbad.
Sobald das geschmolzen ist, nehme ich es runter
und rühre das restliche Drittel ein.
Ich habe seit einiger Zeit die Callebaut-Schokolade, muss ich sagen.
Bin auch sehr begeistert und zufrieden, denn da ist es auch so:
Wenn ich sie einmal nicht 100% temperiere,
also auch nicht diese 2/3, 1/3 abwiege, klappt es trotzdem gut.
Die bin ich jetzt gerade immer noch am Austesten.
Da ist es auch wirklich so,
dass Zartbitterschokolade einfach schon von Natur aus vegan ist,
denn eine gute Schokolade hat nur 3 Zutaten, nämlich
Kakaobutter, Kakao und Zucker. Das war's!
Mehr braucht sie nämlich nicht.
Sollen wir einmal, das wollte ich eigentlich schon länger einmal machen:
Sollen wir einmal so ein Video machen über Schokoladen-Basics?
Dass wir so Schokolade temperieren, so ein bisschen Theorie,
aber jetzt nicht so theoretisch mit Tafel,
sondern so ein bisschen die Schokoladentheorie durchgehen
und wirklich auch zeigen, was man so alles damit machen kann?
Ich glaube, das wäre schon echt cool als Basic-Video, oder Josh?
JOSH: Gehört auch Nougat dazu zum Thema Schokolade?
SALLY: Ja, für dich schon.
JOSH: Ja, dann bin ich dafür.
SALLY: Dann machen wir weiße Schokolade, Vollmilch-, Zartbitter-,
Ruby-, und für Josh mache ich Nougat aus Schokolade.
[Musik]
Jetzt rühre ich den Rest hier rein.
Damit die Kuvertüre beim Anschnitt nicht ganz so bruchfest ist,
kommt gleich noch ein bisschen Kokosöl dazu.
Dann wird sie ein bisschen weicher.
Ihr seht auch,
ich habe hier schon die Biskuitrolle auf ein Abkühlgitter gesetzt.
und darunter eine Schale zum Auffangen der Kuvertüre,
denn man braucht jetzt natürlich
ein bisschen mehr Kuvertüre zum Überziehen.
Der Rest, der dann runtertropft - den kann man weiterverarbeiten
zu Rocky Road z. B. oder Schoko-Crispies
[Musik]
Jetzt ist die Kuvertüre perfekt und ich kann sie
direkt auf die Biskuitrolle gießen
und so ein bisschen mit einer Palette verstreichen.
[Musik]
Die Rolle - eigentlich müsste sie auf der Unterseite auch noch,
aber das lassen wir weg, oder?
Aber eigentlich, wenn ich sie auf Backfolie lege und darunter -
Oh! Dann kann es gut funktionieren.
Aber ich gehe das Risiko nicht ein. Ich stelle sie jetzt...
Ich lasse sie kurz abtropfen. Dann kommt sie in den Kühlschrank
und dann probieren wir die Tender-Rolle.
[Bling]
[Lacht]
Das hat mir keine Ruhe gelassen,
dass es nicht verschlossen ist. Also mache ich das jetzt so.
So.
Ich verschließe noch den Rand. Einfach so. Zack.
So. Gar kein... gar kein Hexenwerk daraus machen.
Dann ist sie von allen Seiten verschlossen.
[Musik]
[Lacht] Die macht Table Dance.
Die Tabledance-Rolle. Wuup! Wuup!
Put your hands up in the air. Put your hands up in the air.
Die macht einen Breakdance. [Lacht]
Ich sehe die Kommentare: "Jetzt dreht sie durch!"
JOSH: [Lacht] Jap.
[Musik]
SALLY: Seid ihr bereit?
MURAT: Ja!
SALLY: Gut. Ich würde sagen, ihr probiert noch einmal die Originale.
MURAT: Ich habe sie vorhin gegessen. Ich muss ehrlich sagen,
ich habe das schon lange nicht mehr gegessen.
SALLY: Okay.
MURAT: Ich fand's ein bisschen zu süß.
SALLY: Ja.
MURAT: Aber der Geschmack ändert sich mit dem Alter.
SALLY: Ist okay das Außenstück für euch?
MURAT: Ja.
SALLY: Ich kippe es mal um,
[Samira staunt]
dass man es sieht.
Ja, ich finde innen...
MURAT: Darf ich mal sehen?
SALLY: Kann sich schon sehen lassen.
MURAT: Hmm! Okay.
SALLY: Ich mache immer normalerweise nach dem Schnitt sauber.
Okay.
MURAT: Da, Samira.
SAMIRA: Danke.
Schokolade...
MURAT: Und du hast jetzt zartbitter gemacht, gell?
SALLY: Hmm! Ja, ich mag Vollmilchschokolade...
haben wir gerade das Ding zerstört. [Lacht]
So alle einmal reingestochen.
Ich krieg's auch gar nicht auf die Gabel, gell? Aufgepickt mit...
[Samira und Sally lachen]
MURAT: Boah, das schmeckt echt gut.
Mmh!
SALLY: Mmh!
MURAT: Schmeckt echt viel besser.
Aber der Fairness halber muss man auch sagen:
Das ist halt frisch und ohne die ganzen Zusatzstoffe. Oder?
[Sally stimmt zu]
So fair muss man sein. Ich meine, wenn die Rolle jetzt
3 Monate lang an der Tankstelle...
SALLY: Die kannst du dann nicht mehr essen.
MURAT: Ja.
SALLY: Aber, was dir auch an der Rolle, glaube ich, besser schmeckt:
Ich habe ja auch mehr Creme drin - und das war hier schon weg.
MURAT: Wenig drin, ja.
Man sieht gar keine Creme, was ich schade finde,
denn auf der Rolle oder auf dem Bild ist Creme dabei.
Also ich finde die voll lecker.
MURAT: Auf Bildern sehe ich auch besser aus.
Sag nichts Falsches.
SALLY: Okay. Falls ihr das Rezept nachbacken wollt
von unsere XXL Milka Tender-Rolle,
dann findet ihr es auf Sallys-Blog.de.
Ich wünsche euch viel Spaß beim Nachbacken.
Schreibt mir gerne in die Kommentare, welche Süßigkeit
oder welches Original ich als Nächstes nachmachen soll.
Ich habe gesehen, die gibt es auch mit Nuss. Ich wäre Nuss-Fan.
MURAT: Ich wäre auch Nuss-Fan.
SALLY: Oh! Mit Pistazien!
[Samira staunt, Murat stimmt zu]
MURAT: Wäre mit Pistazien noch besser.
SALLY: Mit einer richtig leckeren Pistazien-Creme.
MURAT: Ehrlich! Heute kann ich ehrlich sein. Schmeckt echt gut!
SALLY: Wow! Bist du sonst nicht ehrlich?
MURAT: Doch, schon!
SALLY: Er ist zurzeit echt richtig gemein zu mir.
Er sagt dann immer: "Das Essen schmeckt nicht
und es fehlt Fleisch!" und keine Ahnung.
MURAT: Ja, ich bin halt...
Du machst in letzter Zeit sehr viel mit Gemüse.
SALLY: ... vegetarisch.
[Murat lacht]
MURAT: Ja.
SALLY: Tut dir auch gut.
MURAT: Ja. Aber das ist halt Geschmackssache. Einer mag's halt...
Ja.
SALLY: Tschüss!
MURAT: Tschüss!
SALLY: Habt ihr eigentlich unseren letzten Podcast gehört?
MURAT: Welchen Podcast?
SALLY: Ja der von gestern.
MURAT: Welcher war das?
SALLY: Von Donnerstag.
MURAT: Ah okay.
SALLY: Da haben wir über alles geredet.
MURAT: [Auszug aus dem Podcast] Hast du eigentlich auch
eine Rubrik in deinem neuen Buch mit Rezepten, die schmecken?
Der war gut, gell? War saugut. [Lacht]
MURAT: Hä?
SALLY: Könnt ihr euch einmal anhören.
MURAT: Heute ist doch Mittwoch.
SALLY: Nein, heute ist Sonntag.
MURAT: Ja, heute ist Sonntag. Ach so. Hm? Ach so. Hm?
[Murat lacht]
SALLY: Okay, die Wahrheit ist: Heute ist Mittwoch.
MURAT: Ich muss so lachen.
Ich könnte auch nicht 3 Minuten schauspielern.
SALLY: In Wahrheit ist heute Mittwoch
und der Podcast wird erst morgen ausgestrahlt.
MURAT: Genau.
SALLY: Aber du musst so tun, als wäre heute Sonntag...
MURAT: Hmm.
SALLY: ... und als hätten wir ihn am Donnerstag ausgestrahlt.
MURAT: Ja.
SALLY: Kriegst du das hin?
MURAT: Ich hab sie gar nicht verstanden. Macht's gut!
SALLY: Tschüss.
MURAT: Tschüss.
SAMIRA: Tschüss.
MURAT: Einen schönen Sonntag wünsche ich euch übrigens,
auch wenn heute Mittwoch ist oder Donnerstag oder man weiß es nicht.
SALLY: Es ist auch nicht 11 Uhr; es ist 18 Uhr.
MURAT: Ja. Vielleicht ist auch Montag, wenn ihr euch
Montag das Video anschaut.
SALLY: Vielleicht bist du auch gar nicht der Murat, sondern Güni.
MURAT: Vielleicht bin ich gar nicht Murat. Nein.
Vielleicht bin ich auch Manuel Neuer.
[Samira lacht]
Ja.
SALLY: Das wüsste ich. [Lacht]
MURAT: Tschüss.
SALLY: Tschüss. [Lacht]
[Musik]